[Music]
this friday it's time to show the world
who i really am
marvel shanghai lands in theaters
so what's your superhero name going to
be
it's the best superhero film of 2021
whole new level and wildly entertaining
it's the marvel experience you've been
waiting for oh my god
[Music]
marvel shanghai what happened to your
shirt we did pg-13 in peters this friday
hey can we get real for a second we've
been friends for 10 years
i know that you don't like to talk about
your life
but a guy with a freaking machete
foreign arm
just chopped our butts in half
dj snakes
who are you
making major moves my father trained me
to view the 10 rings greatest
[Music]
[Applause]
how did you find me
i always know where my children
are back
seems like a nice fella
it's time to show the world
oh hell no i'm not doing this
[Music]
you are a product of all who came before
[Music]
i must stop him hell yeah
you can hear me
marvel studios sean chi and the legend
of the ten rings in theater september
3rd
[Music]
you